[Music]
you know nothing Jon Snow
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking ferns today I am with
gray area and we are gonna be talking
about Jon Snow hey it's gray area thanks
Dan for having me on your channel thanks
to everyone that's listening we're gonna
be talking about some jon snow so get
ready for the juice ok gray the first
thing I want to talk about with Jon is
pretty much where we left off in season
7 the last time we saw Jon he was on a
ship with Daenerys Tyrion and a few
other people and they were heading to
white Harbor and the last scene with
them pretty much left off with Jon and
Daenerys having sex with each other then
we saw Tyrion basically give that look
of concern so when season 8 begins how
do you think that's gonna play out do
you think Jon and Daenerys are gonna
keep that a secret or do you think
Tyrion may approach them and want to
have some kind of discussion about what
they are doing I think it could go both
ways I think they could try to keep it
private but I feel like everybody that's
on that ship is like in the know right
now they all already know that something
is going down it I don't feel like
Tyrion was the only one in that that
knew so what I don't know if Tyrion look
was about oh this might complicate
things or was it disappoint with the
disappointing did he want Daenerys like
I don't know what that look was about so
I don't know if he'll sit down and talk
to them like just straight go to them
and say yeah I need to talk to you I
think he could maybe do some little sly
remarks do you think Tyrion would tell
them to keep that on the down-low and
keep their relationship a secret or do
you think he could say something else to
them about it
what kind of problems it could cause to
me I feel like Syrian is there as
Daenerys his hand and being Daenerys his
hand I feel like he shouldn't think that
it's gonna complicate things for
Daenerys
if he's gonna complicate things for
anyone it's gonna complicate things for
John
yeah because Daenerys needs allies she
needs a Ally like the king in the north
so he should be grateful for that John
engineers are hook it up now I don't
know if that look was about them
complicating things or if he promised
Cersei something so I won't even go too
far into that because that's another
whole subject but I feel like Tyrion
doesn't want this relationship to happen
for some other reason other than it a
complicated things for Daenerys because
he shouldn't be concerned with if it
complicates things for John because
that's kind of Danville's this job and
Tyrion should just be worried about
Daenerys yeah so you think Jonathan Eris
will keep it a secret for as long as
they can or until the right time I don't
think they're gonna keep it so you think
when they get to Winterfell they will
pretty much announce it or be just
public with it I just think that they'll
just be public with it like they'll just
I don't think they're gonna announce it
like I don't think he's gonna come in
and be like this is my queen I'm gonna
wet her and I've been in her like I
don't think he's gonna say like that but
I think like it would be undeniable to
the people that are looking at them two
together that they're a thing do you
think he got her pregnant that first
time they had sex yes yeah yeah that
that was shoved down our throat like we
had four I think references XI generis
not being able to have kids to John
giving his sword to his son needing an
heir even John said that Mary Messner
was probably wrong with her prophecy
yeah so it was she's pregnant yeah it
was heavily foreshadowed all over season
seven so I'm pretty much 100% confident
she has pregnant yes and I think because
she's pregnant
her and John will definitely get married
because John said he will never father a
bastard absolutely right now if they do
get married like you say do you think
they would do it in front of the heart
tree and Winterfell yes yeah that would
actually be pretty nice yeah cuz the
nares
she doesn't really have any gods
she said that's uh John like I I didn't
put my faith in any gods she put her
faith in herself mm-hm yeah so I could I
definitely think it's gonna be at the
heart tree and it's gonna be at the
Hartree at Winterfell and it'll probably
be very very early in season 8 yeah he
would definitely want to do it before
she gave birth especially if Daenerys
tells John right away that she has
pregnant and did you notice in the last
episode of season seven when we see
Rhaegar and Lyanna getting married in
front of the tree bran is talking about
Rhaegar and Lyanna he's that were
visually seeing them flashback from
their wedding to Jon and Daenerys he
says she loved him and he loved her in
the show John and Danny like staring
into each other's eyes yeah so they're
priming us already for this wedding in
front of a jury yep very similar right
in the godswood another thing I wanted
to ask you is brand saw the wall come
down but depending on how this timeline
goes we don't really know where Jonathan
Ayers was at that point the last scene
we saw them we they were on the boat of
course but obviously they could have
jumped time a little bit and John and
Daenerys could have been closer to white
Harbor they could have been at white
Harbor at that point it's hard to really
say
so when season 8 begins what do you
think the first scene will be do you
think it will be with bran
sent an outward and John and Daenerys
we'll find out at white Harbor when they
were arrived or do you think they will
find out later as they are traveling to
Winterfell or do you think they won't
find out until they reach Winterfell
I think they will find out while they're
traveling to winterville brand
can just warg a raven and get the get
the Raven to John very fast like he
doesn't he need he doesn't need to know
a specific castle that John's gonna be a
he can just warga raven and send that
raven to john he already knows that John
is on his way with Daenerys Targaryen
he told Sam that so all he has to do is
send or work a raven and get it to John
if John and Daenerys do find out the
wall has came down in the night king is
coming south before they get to
Winterfell what do you think John would
do would he try to get to Winterfell
immediately to prepare some kind of
defense or do you think he would try to
gather his forces and meet the night
king in the field somewhere else before
he could reach Winterfell or do you
think he's just gonna go all the way
around it and John will have to fight
him somewhere else I think he's gonna go
to Winterfell I see I could say you
would at what smart what would be smart
is when he gets the white Harbor to take
a ship up the white knife to Winterfell
I feel like that would be a lot faster
[Music]
or something but with TV and limited
time like I feel like John getting a
raven and all that we might not see that
after like that might just be some
things that we just have to explain
later or think about later I feel like
when we when we actually turned on the
TV when the first season 8 opens up it's
gonna be like a cold opening like it was
with artists start killing Walder Frey
and the first episode with the people
beyond the wall I think it will be John
and Daenerys arriving at Winterfell real
ever they're gonna get there they will
be there
hmm so we won't even see white harbor at
all I want us to see white Harbor I feel
like we need to see white Harbor I feel
like white Harbor is important but like
everything just feels so rushed like
realistically I don't know if we're
gonna see white Harbor even though
they've mentioned it so many times they
mentioned
white Harbor at least once every season
really and twice last season every
season twice last season like but I just
feel like the timeline that I feel like
they're gonna be there already yeah they
might just skip all that travel and just
get right to the point
have them showing up at Winterfell I
could see that and that's why I've been
having trouble trying to predict this
first scene judging off of the season
seven storyline because of how one scene
what that character can be at this point
in a timeline and then the next time we
see them the timeline can fast-forward
almost a month so I'm wondering so I'm
wondering if Jon and them will already
know about the night king when we first
see them in season 8 or will we see them
arriving at white Harbor and then they
receive word that's what I'm kind of
confused on because I don't know where
that first scene is gonna begin I feel
like we Cana
it's like so hard because I feel like I
don't want Jon and Daenerys to know
about
vissarion like I want them to kind of
like see it I want them just to see
another dragon in the sky before they
hear about it before they hear about it
there's a lot castles that are more
northern than white Harbor so you kind
of kind of think like how would people
from white Harbor get the news so the
only people that would probably tell
John or Daenerys about this debris
animated Vissarion is brand so hearing
that from brand they might be like so
you're telling me you look into the tree
and turned into a raven and you saw this
dragon alive destroy the wall so I feel
like it would be more impactful to me if
they saw it themselves yeah definitely
would be because they really wouldn't
see it coming although John does know
the night king can raise things but he
would still be shocked that he got that
dragon out of that lake and now he has
it south of the wall so if he showed up
in Winterfell and then he just all of a
sudden heard a
dragon screaming then all of a sudden
that comes down through the clouds like
we've seen Daenerys do so many times
they'd be like holy [ __ ]
he dragon half of that lake and now he's
on it and now he's on our back door
definitely and then he liked it the
night king doesn't even have to be
closed for you to see to see it and know
what it is because I think it's fingers
and dance of dragons like Daenerys
seized rogue on and she knows his drogon
but he's just a speck like he's really
far away yeah but she knows exactly what
it is he was that's hurt her child so
she was to see him from even really
really far away she would know it's him
absolutely then you'd hear him before
you would even seem and you just know
yeah well I see Daenerys dragons right
over there what the hell is that
it definitely would be just that's why I
was struggling to decide with what this
first scene could be because I kind of
feel like the first scene could be with
brand sending out Ravens to every single
every territory every land every village
as many Ravens as he possibly has to
warn them of what's coming and then
that's why I was thinking maybe John and
Daenerys could show up at white Harbor
and maybe the third scene and by then
that Raven would be there if John and
Daenerys docked at white Harbor and
we're getting off the boat that's when
we could see some people had white
Harbor basically running up to them like
you got to get north fast you're not
gonna believe what happened that would
even that would even be more effective
than them like getting to Winterfell and
bran telling them that would be more
offensive it's gonna be exciting and I
really can't wait to see the look on
everybody's face when they see Vasari on
with the night King on him it's gonna be
insane I definitely agree with that with
what you said it would be more impactful
that way another thing I want to talk
about when John shows up in Winterfell
with Daenerys how do you think all the
northern low
and even John's family will treat them
will they accept dinars immediately and
would they accept John if they realize
or know that he's in a relationship with
Daenerys and do you think any of John's
banners could possibly abandon him for
already forming this alliance with
Daenerys and they might even possibly
find out he said he was going to bend
the knee to her how do you think they're
gonna react all that Arya she's gonna
she's gonna be with John Arya is
well-traveled she's been around she's
gonna roll with John no matter what she
loved she loves John nothing if nothing
can make her turn on John she was ready
to kill Santa so the Arya is team John a
hundred percent bran is just heat bran
is gonna do what's best to defeat the
night King if John being with Daenerys
is best to defeat the night King brands
gonna be with team John and Danny
Sansa I'm not sure like she I don't
think she's gonna be with it at all
I don't either I think she's gonna have
a problem with Daenerys at least at
first and I think Yan Royce and maybe
the rest of the Vale might have a
problem with her too
they won't be with it that was
foreshadowed in season 7 they're not
they're anti Targaryen Dan you also have
to think about people that went south
with Brandon Stark that got killed
during the reign of the Mad King because
it wasn't just Brandon Stark and Ric
Rickard stark or yeah it wasn't just
Brandon Stark and Ric arts art they took
people with them too and then a lot of
people rode south and fought and
Robert's rebellion and never came home
so when they show you like the red
wedding the people in the north that I
don't even fool with the Starks they
never will fool with the phrase yeah
pretty clever the red wedding so those
type of bad blood relationships are
gonna be there one person I do
think that is gonna stay pro john is
Lyanna Mormont not only is does she
really fool with John but Daenerys is
has her uncle with him Jorah she jor
will be there he's a Mormon so that
might help things in that department but
I do feel like a lot of people are not
gonna be so dragon friendly and they're
gonna be pissed off because they've
crowned him king in the north
and he gave up his crown and bent the
knee to Daenerys yeah and I can even see
Yan Royce wanting to leave and take the
veil with him and just go back to the
Eyrie and wait out the winter because we
even heard a man from the Vale say why
don't we just go back to our castles and
wait out the storm and when John shows
up with this Targaryen queen who he bent
the knee to I could see them being like
we're out of here
yep and I can see him asking Sansa to go
with them that's possible what do you
think she would say that um I'm not sure
but I think that she might go
I really see songs of having a problem
with this to a point to where it's gonna
cause some tension at a time when they
don't need this kind of tension and John
even tried to remind songs in season 7
when she was talking about having a deal
with Cersei and the army or the war in
the south John's like you don't know
what's coming from the north you haven't
seen it this needs to be our focus and I
think songs it could still be having
that kind of mentality
hopefully that's when Bryan can
hopefully chime in and say Songza you
don't know what I've seen everything
that John says is the truth
we need Daenerys and her dragons if you
want to survive I agree I agree with
that because like you say all right you
have to see it Daenerys said that but
you have to see it to believe it when
John was all healing and recovery on the
ship
she said he was like I'm sorry that we
went and she was like I'm not you have
to see it yeah she said I needed to see
it I needed to know and John is always
saying that like none of you have seen
it I've seen it I feel like it's gonna
be a split like 50% of the people that
he has right now is gonna did yeah and
that's why I feel like we could see a
conversation with Karen about that look
that he gave John and Daenerys when he
knew they were having sex and that's
another reason why I feel like we could
see John and Daenerys decide to keep
their physical relationship a secret
because I think they're gonna know there
will be some tension in the north when
they arrive especially side-by-side and
John's not gonna lie and say that he
didn't bend the knee tour and that he
doesn't support her John's gonna tell
them that so I think they might want to
keep that on the down-low
for as long as possible but then again I
don't know John you know the type of guy
that John is he's not the one to kind of
keep stuff to himself and not tell at
least his family everything that's going
on yeah and I remembered their
conversation where she was like I hope I
hope I deserve it or what about the
people you promised things to Africa how
she worded it but he said they'll
eventually come to see see for what you
are yeah and hopefully it's not too late
hopefully they don't wait until the
night King is at the back door right
because he said eventually he didn't say
they will if their King does he said
eventually they'll see you for what you
are yeah so that pretty much means there
they want at first but they're gonna
have to they're gonna have to accept it
and once they see the threat for
themselves they will know how
desperately they need those dragons they
need those Dothraki men they need the
unsullied they need Daenerys just as
much as Daenerys needs John and his
experience and now Bryan they need
Brandon era's needs bran - she doesn't
know it yet she doesn't know what brain
can provide for them but when they all
arrive in Winterfell they're gonna
here that out yeah but but yes Sansa is
the wild-card and Aria is definitely
gonna be all for it she's not gonna care
either way
so after John arrives in Winterfell and
he finally sees his family again after
all these years when do you think bran
is gonna break that news to John and
tell him about his parentage it's so
hard because there's only six episodes
and you don't know how much time he's
gonna be spent on the night king and how
much time is gonna be spent dealing with
Cersei mm-hmm I want to say that it's
gonna be after the battle with the night
king because John doesn't need to be
distracted from what he needs to do
unless John's parentage is important to
what he needs to do yeah John needs to
know about his Ice and Fire components
to beat the night king yes so if that's
important then I think bran will tell
him will John believe it I think he will
be in denial for at least that episode
yeah I think I don't think he's gonna
believe it at first
I think he may be like really sullen and
brood over it like John Tobey on your
Greyjoy and your Stark and John is gonna
have to take those words what John told
Theon is gonna be what brand tells John
I definitely think that conversation
Johnetta Theon was a foreshadowing for
John having to come to terms with
himself about being Stark and Targaryen
just like you said and I think I think
Samwell Tarly will help kind of
reinforce that with you John really is
and he will also be needed for John to
accept that he is a Targaryen and Ned
was not his father yeah and I think that
was I swear I think that was a
foreshadow and like I'm almost willing
to proof money on it absolutely what do
you think his other family members
we'll think about this how will Sansa
and Arya react to that news about John
who they thought was their brother this
whole time is actually not their brother
and not only is he not their brother he
is the true heir to the Iron Throne
he's a Targaryen that same Targaryen
blood that Sansa does not like
[Music]
[Music]
you